moi j'ai toujours été très à l'aise avec
ce qui aidera gh1 vraiment c'est c'est
ma spécialité
en soirée on se fait tous un peu rire
les uns les autres tu as mais moi des
cas une fille qui me plaît vraiment qui
débarque toi coup j'ai l'impression de
plus du tout à voir d'humour d'être le
mec lourd carrément pas marrant non en
fait je disais juste peut-être la
cigarette électronique ça donnerait le
cancer électronique le nourrir de la
femme quand tu parles à une meuf sur
facebook et sur cette photo elle est
vraiment super rebelle
un petit mannequin moi perso j'ai pas
confiance et je vous disais le plus beau
compliment qu'on puisse faire une fille
en 2014 finalement c'est aussi basé
c'est hyper frustrant quand tu essaies
de draguer de meuf
tu vois que c'est plutôt bien parti et
qu'au fur et à mesure de la conversation
elle te fait comprendre qu a pas moyen
et que tu auras jamais moyens et sinon
ça c'est quoi ton type de mec
j'aime l'apathie sont grands à web
intelligent black et bien musclé ah oui
c'est ça ton que ça s'est massée en
basque et moi de céder à la base
justement la base je devais être noir
c'est vrai je suis mes parents pas pas
voulu trop bête
je sais que le zouk et le collés serrés
ces dépenses pas mal pour séduire mais
quand je vois certaines personnes
dansaient là dessus je me dis que là
c'est plus la séduction c'est carrément
des préliminaires
quand cet abri
le tout
témoin d'un concours
tout comme la il paraît que les femmes
aiment les hommes attentionné et galant
ça c'est normal
par contre un truc que je comprends pas
c'est parfois j'entends certaines filles
dire franchement pour moi le mec parfait
faudrait qu'il soit attentionné à trop
gallant a mais un tout petit peu macho
nous sommes trop watts
comment un mec peut être à la fois
galant et macho
[Musique]
parce que tu vas faire
[ __ ] t'as un peu de repassage et
apprendre en question une baisse trop
sexy et un truc que je trouve vraiment
injuste dans la vie pourquoi quand on
est en couple on attire beaucoup plus
les meufs que quand on est célibataire
forte dans balance ça devrait être mieux
dans l'autre sens
tes copines alors ouais j'ai une copine
on a donc tout couple bah ouais ça je
suis en couple donc tu as dix mois non
je suis à temps ah non mais on a faim on
en fait on a cassé hier en fait en fait
tu célibataire je vais oublier ici je
suis célibataire
il ya certaines filles qui sont mcee et
pour pas qu'on les dragues
elles ont trouvé une technique assez
subtil elles font référence à leurs
copains 45 mille fois par minute et
c'est assez agréable surtout quand à la
base c'est pas du tout venus pour les
derniers tout est cool la soirée un
grave
mon mec il a kiffé moi j'ai ma carrière
samedi soir souvenirs était la bienvenue
m a carrément bah tiens je viendrai avec
mon mac ce qui là une manière le tout ce
sera plus simple
bah ouais ouais je t'enverrai sur sur
facebook l'adresse est trop fine
ouais ok mais tu verras ma photo de
profil c'est mon mec et moi et mon
statut c'est en coupe
ah bah ouais j'aurais pas de mal à
trouver du mal à trouver un grand
classique un la base
tout le monde connaît ce genre de mec
qui drague dans la rue de cette manière
la france monte trop jolie et au calme
tout propre et bien s coupé et au fait
t'es trop moche est un gros hic je
demandais pourquoi il faisait ça qu'a
fait logique être ça se trouve les mecs
c'est pas leur faute ils sont juste des
problèmes de vue il voit il voit mal de
prêt puis en fait ils voient bien de
loin après était jolie est franchement
du trou je hais
elle n'en fait pas un groupe est en fait
t'es trop moche ça va pas j'ai pas bien
vu et je vois pas bien le rêve de tous
les mecs c'est que d'une meuf vient
d'accoster dans la rue alors pourquoi
des fois les meufs quoi nous à cause
dans la rue elles disent cette phrase
nul ce qui doit je rassure un job et
agde radeau genre ça nous rassure
atépa la pompe draguer j'avoue ça me
rassure team il ne serait venu pour me
marier serait peut-être horrible ça
serait pécho et où je vais tellement
armand draguer tout des fois qu'il ya
des filles qui vient clairement me
draguer j'ai l'impression qu'elle se
fout de ma gueule
je trouve vraiment très drôle super la
vanne mais manquait toujours te trouve
trop sexy tu fais craquer bon c'est bon
c'est une caméra cachée tu as fait tu as
fini on peut arrêter tu puisses la
blague un petit peu loin là ça va on a
compris c'est marrant on a bien rigolé
nous passer à autre chose
franchement rien ne vaut la bonne
vieille technique du texto ou choisissez
unité qui vous plaît dans votre
répertoire l'a voulu envoyer un petit
message
j'ai même pas eu le temps d'écrire en
fait ça m'a rejeté mais je n'ai pas à
pas comme ça comme quoi parfois les
photos c'est c'est bon c'est parfois
trompeurs un peu la magie d'un
clairement à la magie d'internet n'a pas
une vie terne ne vient pas tant je me
suis relâché comme ça allait passer
[Musique]
forcer les barras a on verra au
développement mais à
parce j'ai beau petit talent de
photographe